chef Gabriele quarter is one of the
world's most highly regarded maestro's
of the kitchen and though he was born in
France's greatest impact has come here
in America after culinary school he
worked his way through Michelin star
kitchens in France Germany and
Switzerland arriving here in New York in
1997 he immediately began racking up the
award in june of last year he put his
own name on what's become one of his
country's most honored restaurants
Gabrielle coy 30 in midtown Manhattan
holds a Michelin star and three stars
from the New York Times so we are
honored to welcome chef Gabrielle cry
third to the dish good morning good
morning tell us what you brought what
today about a baker off which is a
traditional dish when I las voces parts
with bacon I have a green green salad
with a lot of herbs fine herbs in it I
have google off with that chive deep
catsuits I think these are the first
pretzels we've had on the show my QB
this is a horseradish tip that goes a
whole sadish tip that goes with the
pretzels for the pretzel is fresh so you
break it down and you give it the enemy
that's beautiful and here we have a bob
our warm which is a really traditional
these organizers and and I grew up with
that so that's the stuff i grew up with
really on the farm i have a sense you
did not grow up with this cocktail not
really not really not what is in this
this is the hidden here you have gone
man yay you have whiskey and you have my
mouth it's a three little three simple
ingredients and then it's finished up
with a little bit of energy very nice so
you know as a mother of a four year old
when i read that for years old you knew
you wanted to be a chef around that time
i was really impressed what guided you
at that time how did you know this is
what you know i go up on a farm and that
was always my whole family was involved
in food business and since since my
earliest time I always wanted to be a
chef and I remember my grandfather has
been asking me what you wanted to want
to be and I always said I want to be a
chef about a beer chef are going to be a
chef and one of my uncle's used is a
chef and I walked in his kitchen
starting at 11 12 years old during the
school vacations and he always made me
do some little walk and then some dirty
work to make sure that I really want to
do that right it's only later that they
told me that that it made me it's dirty
stuff to kind of like make sure
that's that's why they wanted to do you
were 19 years old when you were awarded
best kitchen apprentice and friends yes
yeah what did that how did that change
things for you uh it opened a lot of
doors it it it was it was a tough
contest it was exciting it was a
challenge for me and I took it seriously
and I find when I won it opened the
doors for me that was the first time
that I came to the united states and i
spent 18 months in washington DC at the
time and i went first conversation go
because i know the idea came up someone
said to you would you want to go to the
United States yes your first thought
that once at the wards somebody showed
up in front of me and said Washington DC
you wanna go and like I don't know I
don't even thought about it that said
yes and when everything was over my
mother said but did you just tell them I
said I'm going to Washington DC she said
you know you're kidding I said no I'm
going there for 18 months well you ended
up meeting your wife here so you need
one bad right now I went back actually
for about ten ten years and then I came
back again yes yeah I went back I had to
do my military stuff all these things I
had to gain more experience over there
when I was festivities and friends my
uncle told me is like calm down no it's
only starting for you well you mentioned
that experience when you look at your
resume you spend a lot of time at some
of the most top-tier restaurants in New
York yes before deciding to go out on
your own yeah why did you wait so long
was that a conscious choice oh you know
it was yeah it was a conscious choice I
spent five years with John George Danny
opened I opened stab it for about two
years and when I was at the at the
modern I spent ten years there but
something to remember is that during
those ten years we had literally five
years of a huge recession so I don't at
the time I didn't think it was a smart
idea to try to open a business doing
doing such a hard time yeah I know that
you were responsible for ushering in the
new era of fine dining and we can
certainly see why it's an amazing meal
as we get your signature on this dish
you want to ask if you could have this
mail with any person past or present who
would that person be oh it will be
Auguste Escoffier hyster is the father
of all the chefs of the modern chefs and
I think it would be great for me to
listen to his his his take on how
everything the evolution of fine dining
the evolution of food
Woods and I think we would have a great
job good pick chef Gabrielle Kreutzer
thank you so much and for more on the
chef and the dish please head to our
website at cBS This Morning Calm